In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for June 6th, on which we commemorate our Righteous Father
Ilarion, the new.
On the 6th of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father Ilarion, Abbot of the
Monastery of Dalmatus.
Our Holy Father Ilarion originally came from Cappadocia, where his father provided bread
for the imperial palace and enjoyed a favored position, entering the monastery of Zerocopion
in Constantinople at the age of 20.
He soon left it for the celebrated monastery of Dalmatus, where he was tonsored monk.
Humble and a lover of Hisichia, his obedience for ten years, was to work in the garden,
where his virtues shown forth.
As he had cast out a demon from a young boy by his prayers, the Abbot ordered that he
be ordained priest, in spite of his reluctance.
And sometime after the death of the Abbot, as the monks wished to make him Abbot, Ilarion
left to take refuge in the monastery of Katharra in Bithinia.
The monks of Dalmatus, however, appealed to Patriarch Nikefodos and to the emperor, who
sent him back to their monastery, and he was named Abbot by the Holy Synod and the
Archimandrite of the monasteries of the capital in 807.
He was peacefully directing his spiritual flock, when Leo, the Armenian, began the iconoclast
persecution once more.
The saint was brought before the sovereign, who tried to make him renounce the veneration
of the holy icons, but he firmly stood his ground, treating the emperor as an atheist
and a new apostate.
Furious, Leo had him tortured and thrown into prison.
After a prolonged detention, Ilarion was brought before the emperor once more, where he repeated
his former words.
Leo handed him over to the heretical patriarch, Thildotus Cassiteras, in the hope that the
latter would be able to convince the valiant confessor and, along with him, the powerful monastic
party.
Thildotus failed, and Ilarion was shut up in a dark dungeon, without food for many days.
His disciples, hearing that he was about to die from hunger, went to beg the emperor to
release him, promising that their spiritual father would submit to his will.
Leo freed him and allowed him to return to his monastery, but he soon realized that he
had acted like a fool, and the saint was shut up for six months in the monastery of
funnels, on the bospheres, where he was subjected to ill treatment by the abbot, who had been
one to the emperor's cause.
After appearing once more before the tyrant, Ilarion was transferred to the monastery of
Kiklobion, on the west side of the capital, where he remained for two and a half years,
after which he was interned in the prison of the Numerians near the palace, once he was
taken to the fortress of Proteleon, after having been cruelly beaten.
After Leo was assassinated in the church where he had begun his persecution by throwing an
icon of Christ to the ground, Michael II, taking power, ordered that the confessors be freed
in 820.
Ilarion was released, but was forbidden to enter this city.
He was given shelter for seven years by a devout Christian, until the beginning of Thelfilos'
reign.
He, seeking out the monastic superiors who were confessors of the holy icons, had them brought
before him one by one.
When they asked Ilarion whether he would submit to the imperial will, the saint condemned
the tyrant, accusing him of being an impious deceiver.
Without pity for his age, they inflicted 117 blows on him, and then had him deported to
the island of Afusia, to the south of Proponthes.
There the saint dug out a narrow cell in the rock, and by his prayer made a spring of fresh
water flow from the rock.
He spent eight years there in Hezekiah, until the death of Thelfilos and 842.
Saint Ilarion was immediately authorized to return to Constantinople by the Empress Theodora,
and to take up the direction of his monastery once more.
Having been present at the triumphal restoration of Orthodoxy, he spent three years instructing
his monks in the holy traditions, shining radiantly by the sanctity of his life and his miracles.
In 845, at the age of 70, he gave his soul into the Lord's hands.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.